hallo leute ich es wieder mal waren und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge wie
schmeckt ihr könnt euch nicht vorstellen
wie lange ich schon dieses käsebrot
machen ich glaube ich habe vor zwei
monaten ist das erste mal machen wollen
und dann hatten die mit der zeit nicht
geklappt und dann war irgendwie noch was
anderes und dann köln und dann sowieso
aber heute ist es endlich soweit sie
nicht wissen wovon ich spreche ich
spreche von dem käse brot was der
großvater also der immer für heidi
gemacht als kind dachte ich immer dass
muss das leckerste käsebrot auf der welt
seien das allerletzte dieser krise
einfach zu seiner weichen masse
geschmolzen ist und ist so lecker aus
ich habe für die recherche ungefähr zehn
folgen heini gucken müssen um zu sehen
wie dieser großvater dieses käsebrot
macht und dann habe ich endlich eine
folge gefunden es ist die folge in der
heidi gerettet von zwei jägern also das
reh versteckt sich unter heidi und dann
sagt soweit die bitte nicht nicht
schießen und dann sagen wir zwei jäger
jetzt geht zur seite oder der schichten
welches war ein bisschen dramatisch muss
ich sagen lange geschichte kurz heidi
hat es geschafft das reden zu retten
die zwei jäger sind dann weitergezogen
und in einen schneesturm geraten und
dann hat heidis großvater so heldenhaft
bier ist die zwei jäger gerettet sorry
für den spoiler aber die story
interessiert uns nicht uns interessiert
nur wie dieses käsebrot vom großvater
schmeckt und ich haben schritt für
schritt screenshots gefunden
wie der großvater das macht zuerst holte
mit dem ziegenpeter den käse und das
brot aus dem schrank da seht ihr noch
mal wieder käse aussieht ich denke es
ist ein mentaler weil er solche löcher
hat wie ein emmentaler dann steckt er
den käse auf ein starkes über die flamme
und legte es aufs brot sind ziemlich
dickes brot und dann sitzen sie alle
glücklich am tisch weil dieses käsebrot
ungefähr das leckerste auf der welt sein
muss ende
es scheint ziemlich simpel zu sein also
let's go da gibt es allerdings ein
problem wir brauchen feuer und da ich
nicht vorhabe in meiner küche ein feuer
zu machen müssen wir nach draußen also
los lasst uns nach draußen gehen mit
unserer magischen treppe bevor wir
draußen ein feuer machen können müssen
erstmal susan fragen auf den worten
feuer machen können
kann mir draußen und feuermachen
dankeschön super gerne darf ich das
machen jetzt sind wir draußen ich habe
alles besorgt was man für heidis käse
brot braucht und das ist der emmentaler
ja schönes landbrot schöne musik haben
vom 1
und ich habe noch eine sache besorgt
ziegenmilch denn der aufmerksame
zuschauer sieht natürlich dass heidi und
peter immer aus so einer holzschale
ziegenmilch trinken also die haben ja so
eine ziege da heißt die eigentlich
schlucken schnucki ich glaube sie heißt
schnucki wird immer gemolken und dann
trinken sie die ziegenmilch käse kenne
und mag ich eigentlich auch aber ist
euch mal aufgefallen dass ziegenkäse
einfach nachts ihr geschmeckt stellt
euch mal vor rindfleisch würde einfach
nach kühen schmecken würde echt wenig
auf wie schmeckt siebenmeter aber wie
machen wir jetzt ein feuer hier raus
nichts leichter als das dafür braucht
ihr nur einen coolen barbecue metall
eimer und natürlich die gute grill
holzkohle lang anhaltende glut die natur
her war gab ich bin grillanzünder aber
pasta auf change man hätte mich auch
danger wandel zuerst müssen wir diese
richtig fetten droht scheiben schneiden
die cs habe jetzt eine abneigung gegen
ich sie es bekommen was ist da dass ich
31 stunden im ep waren köln nach hab ich
es nicht erzählt sind nicht meine story
team gesehen haben wir das in die titel
ein lied backen oder was dass sie
tatsächlich aus so ein schönes landbrot
macht das hier weg und das ist ein
frisches brot noch ein ece schon okay
der richtig fette scheibe ihr chef doch
nicht doch so eine scheibe war ist ist
meine scheibe war jetzt kommt unser ganz
hochwertiger toller krise sind
feinschmecker lang habe ich den hier
sowohl jetzt schneiden wir denken was so
fettes brot mit einem fetten stück käse
noch ic
jetzt wo wir unsere zutaten vorbereitet
haben geht's ans kochen das ist nur eine
region des ok region für mich wieso
nicht mehr da war da mühsamer arbeit im
bergwerk haben wir das so sagen weh
richtig merkt man oft schon im bergrecht
gearbeitet mein großvater hat schon im
bergwerk gearbeitet und jetzt brauchen
unser grillanzünder game changer ich
kann die augen feuer in der freien natur
machen habt ihr gesehen beim programm
das video ich bin richtig gut jetzt da
bin aber froh dass richtline tankstelle
die kleinen anzünder naja zum letzten
castaway gesehen ich habe fehler gemacht
[Musik]
ich hab so seien gefragt und hat gesagt
ich darf
50 1 regel der eine hat eigentlich so
eine stange auf die er den käse drauf
packt aber da ich keine stelle gefunden
habe habe ich hab nur heute sagen die
wahrscheinlich verbrennen salons
schmilzt damit einem schweizer käse dann
lief es noch nicht so richtig heißen
geil den sperr baue ich mir ich habe
mich entschieden doch ein stock zu
nehmen oakley baby das wird was kann ihn
ja auch dreh wie einen döner spieß also
ich glaube ich hab noch nie so dumm ist
wie schnitzen oder schwitzen schon sehr
schnell
na wenn das nichts wird jetzt tropft
wieder runter und richtig man hier
ok ja er hat er hat die konsistenz kann
man auf jeden fall noch okay jetzt ist
der moment gekommen in dem das probieren
die krise ist so weich geworden
das ist es dass käse brot von heidi was
da auf sie gemacht haben aber ganz
ehrlich das kann gar nicht sein dass der
diesen käse auf diesem stab hatte das
funktioniert nicht das ding jetzt runter
jetzt stellen wir uns natürlich wieder
der allerwichtigste frage wie schmeckt
das käsebrot aushalten
wow da schmeckt damit gut und dadurch
dass das brot einmal hingefallen ist
dass er theoretisch schön knusprig ich
will auch einfach nur den käse nach so
einem fetten käsebrot habe ich richtig
lust auf ziegenmilch wir trinken
natürlich aus einer schüssel denn
welcher gab es damals nicht wie normale
milch
großvater ich habe einen stelle
sinnvoller ziegenmilch monnet war warum
sollte man sie nicht trinken
es schmeckt wie flüssiger ziehen
also wenn ihr einmal richtig umständlich
grillkäse auf brot machen wollt dann
nehmt euch einen stock und haltet den
käse über die flamme bisher euch 100
fällen aber ansonsten ist das ein
ziemlich leckeres brot die ziegenmilch
würde ich auf keinen fall empfehlen
ziegenmilch schmeckt so eklig und
ansonsten hoffen natürlich hat das video
gefallen wenn ja dann gibt einen daumen
nach oben das hilft mir gut weiter und
wenn ihr weitere rezeptvorschläge habt
aus filmen oder serien oder eurer
liebsten kinderserie vielleicht dann
schreibt sie in die kommentare
ich freue mich und sonst sind hier noch
zwei andere videos schaut sich gerne an
wie schlägt unser aller lieblings vom
rad und nächstes mal wieder in meiner
küche